tell me why you're doing this why do you
do it money and the title uh Breaking
Bad what exactly does that mean I'm not
cool enough to understand no you know
what you're you're you're very cool it's
just uh no one's ever heard of it before
I I come from Virginia and uh it's a
very much a southern regionalism that I
thought everybody knew it means to raise
hell oh okay so he's like I was at the
other night at the bar and I just tied
one on and I really broke bad I just
really oh man I just wind up in the back
of a squad car
so it's a regionalism some straight like
you giant stick up his ass all of a
sudden at age what 60 he's just gonna
break back but I and I named it Breaking
Bad and uh the first the script when it
went out either people are too polite to
question it or something I remember the
head of Sony said can't you think of a
better title and I said well I kind of
like this one he says I don't know what
the hell it means but I thought
everybody I didn't realize it was a it
was as Regional an expression as it is